non c'est les 5 qui règles d'accueil et
passe par son don ouais bon enfant ce
pourquoi on est là pour faire des tests
de foule avant tout aux annonces en
pause
je suis pas ce qu'ils foutent la m là je
vais aller voir l'intérieur
quand on rentrait tu l'as pas faire et
pas d'essayer l'inscription septembre
aux stups où l'homme régime gbagbo
sauf qu il est du coup je joue bien
c'est beau de le regarder jouer
audrey d'invités au mariage
mais des cadenas devenu jour de foot je
sais pas c'est pas compliqué tu veux pas
demandé deux anciens collègues de
regarder un gamin jouer parce que toi ta
merde et il faut que tout le monde mais
rld est de faire du bois si on monte en
finale cette année par miracle parce que
j'ai un joueur devrait jouer c'est vous
c'est moi oui